[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ما في شك
اساليب الفنيه الاساليب الادبيه التيارات
بشكل عام المبدعين عددهم تمركزهم الوسائل
التي تخدمهم وسائل عرضهم هذه كلها طبعا
تشكل ذائقه مجتمع في فتره معينه في مرحله
معينه عبر وسائل ايضا معينه ما في شك طبعا
وممكن ايضا هذه تجني على المجتمع يعني اذا
عودناهم على
الجمال الدائم او على الاقل اذا كثر او
بالغنا فيه يتحول الى عبء عبء جمالي يعني
فيصير في مشكله ايضا في تقبل اي حركه
جديده فيما بعد يعني يصير في صعوبه في
تقبل حتى المختلف المختلف حتى بالزمن او
بالجيل يصير في ايضا حتى صعوبه في تقديم
النفس يعني المبدع الجديد كيف يقدم نفسه
المبدعه الجديده كيف تقدم نفسها يعني ممكن
يكون عبء عاده التوازن بالامور هذه تاخذ
فتره
بعد ما تنتهي حاله الضجيج او حاله
المعاصره ترشح الامور فتتضح الرؤيه
[موسيقى]
اعتبرها مستوى عالي بسبب بسيط جدا
وهل بسيط هذا هو اساسي الثقافه العربيه
يعني من اهم
انتاجاتها الثقافيه الشعر
والفنون والاداب كلها قائمه على النص يعني
حتى نكاد احنا من باب المبالغه طبعا هذا
وليس حقيقه طبعا انه نقول انه كل فروع
الادب من الشعر لكن الاغنيه تقوم على
الشعر ايضا حتى التمثيل سواء المسرح شعري
او حتى كتابه شعريه حتى في الدراما طبعا
يعني او حتى دراما الاذاعيه والتلفزيونيه
ذاق الشعريه اعتقد انها هي الصمام الامان
في المجتمعات العربيه
وهي دائما النقطه او المفتاح الاساسي
عندما يتلقون الاغنيه يبحثون او يركزون
على النص
فيما بعد حسب خبرات الشخص الفرديه
قد يعني يتذوق اللحن صوت الاداء الالات
الامور الاخرى التقنيه ايضا لكن الشعر
العربي ما زال حتى الان واعتقد انه
ما خان المجتمع العربي نهائيا
[موسيقى]